verbally attacked in front of families
with children just for being Muslim that
yelling continued for almost 30 minutes
and IU student is now facing multiple
charges 19 year-old Tristan Bickford is
accused of verbally attacking a Muslim
woman Salam alaikum guys how are you
doing I'm with our salon from care from
the Seattle chapter now yeah we were
talking about these terms derogatory
terms that are thrown out there and many
people they you know just kind of just
go along with the flow like radical
Islam Islam is and what was the other
ones well there's also I don't use them
because they're bad words is also the J
word the T word the R word and many many
more words that are message tested to
trigger fears and people's minds you
really you you're saying you really
don't use it you didn't use it but for
those people that don't know what we're
talking about because it's uh spelled it
out for you so te r ro r word again is T
is M it's also the other word jihad
jihad and then ending with is G is M how
come you don't just say it well because
these words are meant to defame and
they're you know I saw the movie the
butler
you might remember and when he
and talk to someone and says you know I
don't say that either actually but
someone slapped him and says you know
these are other people's words they're
full of hate I just got after the
Americans at that time yeah so same
thing here these are these are words
that that are invented by our opponents
and they're their message tested to
trigger hate and fear against us and
they've become so common through
repetition that even we and our allies
use these words anyway so if you go to
care Seattle CAIR Seattle org slash
Seattle Times you'll find the research
that we did on the Seattle Times
coverage the interns at care Seattle did
and we found that words like the I word
is L AM is T E is M where we used 388
times in one year in the year 2012
two-thirds of that time they were used
to describe a Muslim person in a violent
negative way the J word was used 120
times 120 times only once was it used to
describe a person's struggle every other
time it was used to describe negative
violence by Muslim persons so really
these are code words that are that are
meant to trigger fear and hate they're
full of hate and they're words that we
need to get rid of from style books and
style guides they're some of these words
are codified in style guides now the
Islamism Islamist is in the AP Stylebook
it wasn't there until the year 2010 or
2011 so it's the work of our opponents
of anti-muslim hate groups to codify
these terms to become to normalize them
and to make them words that we see now
literally hundreds of times a day what's
wrong with them well you know when we
see hate crimes rising in the last eight
years not when in 2011 not in 2001 2000
2003 but in the last eight years is when
we've seen hate crimes rise and we've
seen public opinion of Islam drop
drastically in the last eight years not
when you might think it would have
happened but recently we've also seen
these exact same words that are used in
headlines everything
being used by people who are attacking
children and women right so the same
slurs that are being used about us in
mainstream headlines not right-wing or
left-wing what mainstream media are
being used by people who are attacking
and often killing Muslim persons so you
see the connection between hate speech
and hate crimes hate speech leads to
hate crimes and we have to make sure
that mainstream media those that call
themselves mainstream and honest are
using accurate terms to tell our stories
it's just it's our job to actually you
know tell those stories and it's our job
to have mainstream media be more
responsible be more accurate and be
informative in the way that tell and
educate the average person their job is
to use words that help understand
interest understanding and the job is to
get rid of words that become obstacles
in our understanding how much is
actually spent annually it's become a
big business if you want to make money
Sheriff
you know this manufactured hate you fear
the Islamophobia machine how much is
actually spent you know yearly on this
negative this false propaganda against
Muslims in Islam yeah so according to
Cara's research about 210 million
dollars were spent just in the past few
years by few just a few foundations to
fund anti-muslim hate groups is also the
inner core of anti-muslim groups that
just do anti-muslim work and nothing
else it's also the outer core if you go
to Islam a phobia org Islamophobia org
you'll find this data out there it's
very easy to find online but the real
focus again is the impact that it has on
the lives of women children our own
families that's the real impact top of
the money it's about the impact is
having in our lives again hate crimes
against Muslims and American Muslims are
at record highs today this year not back
when you might have thought they were
have been highest this year might be a
recommendation year in US history of
hate crimes against American Muslims
that's really our job again to make sure
that our neighbors and allies
using language that helps us helps our
neighbors understand our lives and
definitely not use terms that I have
been coined have been researched tested
to trigger fears against our our
families do you have any story a real
story that people who have come from
this this perspective how they've been
kind of affected by the hate machine but
they've actually connected with you guys
that care or they've connected with some
us judge with some people and they've
had a change of heart when they've
really gotten to connect with message
have you had anybody like that you know
I haven't met people personally myself
my good friends in the Seattle area have
told some good stories about people who
met with American Muslims in a local
mosque and you know it's really a matter
of telling our stories and educating
people that our lives our hopes our
dreams our children our families and
when people come to understand that
Americans simply want to have their
children succeed and their families have
seen in the traditional American way
that working hard and making sure their
kids are getting good education is when
they understand them and they hear those
stories that's when they turn around and
come to see us as their neighbors and
our job again is to help our own
community members keep the focus on our
stories our contributions and not repeat
the information that's put out by the
other other at the other side simply to
tell our stories all day every day and
use every platform to have social media
emails to editors speeches that we make
to keep telling our stories and help
people understand our families our lives
our hopes and dreams what advice do you
have do you guys give people who are
feeling discriminated they're facing
this as Islamophobia what advice do you
give for them
number one report cases you know you
you helped not only yourself but the
entire community each time you report a
case to your local care office and if
you want to find a local office anywhere
in the country just simply go to care
comm CAI are calm so CAI are calm
towards the bottom there it'll tell you
all the chapters that we have and if you
don't have a chapter in your local state
which is called a national office at two
oh two four eight eight eight seven
eight seven two oh two four eight eight
eight seven eight seven or just email
info at care comm or you can actually
download the app CAI are calm /ap P so
care calm slash app once you have that
app you can report cases right there on
your phone and you get daily news briefs
as well so reporting cases not only
helps you because we are then able to
provide free legal help to help you but
it also helps us document cases and
again by telling your story we're able
to actually see trends so suppose you
have something happen to your daughter
at a school and suppose we get another
case from a different school but in the
same school district then we can start
saying well you know there might be
something more than just one case going
on here and let's take it up with the
school district and let's make sure this
systemic changes that are made to
prevent these things from happening cuz
it seems like it's happening more than
once but I wouldn't know that unless we
got in cases from many people
so reporting really helps it doesn't
just help you it helps our entire
community and as close with what we
started in the beginning derogatory
names that are concoct
Islam is you don't want to say him I'm
the approach of that the bad words right
you know jihadist radical Islam for the
leaps many of our community leaders who
fall into an H star repeating these
words what advice do you have to them
well you know just know that these words
are research tested to trigger fears in
people's minds and that's why our
opposition has coined them it repeat
them over and over again or mess in
their messaging and you mentioned the
other the funding that ng Muslim groups
have it's not really about the funding
is that well the well-coordinated work
they're doing so the same messages
you'll hear from anti-muslim groups that
are right-wing anti-muslim groups and
then a left wing that are in all walks
of life because they know that those
words have power your you know your
words become your thoughts your thoughts
become your actions that really is true
I mean repeat something over over again
enough times it taints that community
with that with that term with that idea
that's kinda what's been happening with
American Muslims and I really mean that
I mean American Muslims according to all
norm research if you go to see Islam
factcheck.org Islam factcheck.org go
find research like American with some
women being the second highest educated
religion of a woman in the country and
American with some medical doctors
there's 50,000 Americans in medical
doctors that means one out of every 18
medical doctors in the country is saving
lives every day
thousands upon thousands of police
officers serving our country so the
facts are so far removed from what
you're hearing in the media that it's
really our job to focus on the facts and
not use terms that are again research
tested to trigger fears against American
Messiah
thank you very much brother for sharing
gosh my pleasure thanks again if you
guys have any questions you want to
learn more about Islam don't go to the
Islamic folks come to us continue to
tune in every week to D show you see you
next time peace with you tsunami